on this episode I answer a shitload of
questions you ask questions and I answer
them this is the askgaryvee show
[Music]
what's up everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 71 of
the askgaryvee show we decided since 71
is such a special number and you know
such a significant number that we're
gonna have a very special show it's
going to be called the rapid fire show
[Music]
so India are you ready this is gonna be
pretty intense do you rock you ready
let's get in to the show Tim ask if
you're not from an english-speaking
country should you produce content in
English anyways or should you produce
content in your mother language Tim
that's a great question with a very
simple answer which is great because I'm
answering a boatload of questions today
the answer is you should be speaking in
the language of the people you're trying
to reach so if you're trying to reach
the consumers in your native tongue
speak in your native tongue unless
English is also the second language and
is covering let's say 80 90 percent of
the speakers because then you get the
serendipity if it goes outside the
boundaries but it always is reverse
engineering the language of your client
if you're trying to reach
english-speaking consumers then you've
got to speak in English and again if
English is enough of a second language
with a big enough broad stroke according
to the overall market that would be the
reason the rationale around English
otherwise it's a native tongue game Tom
Riley asked Trader Joe's has a cult-like
following with no social media presences
what are your thoughts Tom I think
Trader Joe's is leaving action on the
table you know I don't know what else to
say clearly their business is great and
I keep saying it marketing great
marketing doesn't solve a business's
problem but it can accelerate a
business's enormous awesomeness I don't
know nothin sound right but the bottom
line is very simply Trader Joe's you may
be thinking that you're doing it cool or
that brand shouldn't engage if they're
awesome and you're a great brand but I
fundamentally believe they're leaving a
lot of action on table I love when
people like yo Gary I don't mean social
media or good marketing my business is
up 23% I'm like what's wrong with 60%
like why can't your business be up 90%
Joe
Luke asks my little sister has Instagram
and snapchat but has no interest in
Facebook what do you think the future
roles for Facebook Luke I think Facebook
has an issue about the growing
population I don't see your little
sister and her little friends jumping
from snapchat and instant into Facebook
as they get older
no instant snapshot will become more
like Facebook but well Facebook be in a
place where it will be able to keep its
35 to 70 year olds on its platform and
not have them go down to instant
snapchat
listen sucks is an assassin there's a
reason he bought Instagram there's a
reason trying to pay 3 billion let me
just remind the markets stunwin Stevens
out here often these days let's just
show him he's like all super VIP and
never around anymore you know he tried
to buy snapchat for 3 billions so I
think what the future holds for Facebook
is if they keep crushing it and doing
the things they're doing which I think
they're doing well and they hold on to
their 30 30 to 35 and above crowd it'll
be an enormous business but over time
that will corrode over 15 20 30 years
but don't forget instant is the new
Facebook right now and so they've got a
long lineage they'll have to make sure
that they get the next one after
snapchat and that's probably their
biggest vulnerabilities for a decade out
game but don't forget they bought oculus
and so there's a they're doing a lot of
stuff look at them like a Google you
know Facebook is is the infrastructure
for over-the-top television or for free
internet in America or has the number
one phone in seven years that wouldn't
surprise me because that's where I think
sucks is leadership is taking them
Melissa asks hey Gary morale in public
education is low how can i as a teacher
help to create a Thank You economy
culture despite government mandates an
effective curriculum low funding and
most of all high stress and pressure on
teachers Melissa you can't the the
machine is too big it's too broken and
what you can do as an individual I think
is do what I do with the askgaryvee show
which is you know I think I'm doing
education here you can put out great
content to the universe using the
platforms that can reach people and so
trying to change an entire machine is
extremely difficult I with all my
charisma and energy and clout can't move
big you know corporate 500 organizations
you want to move the entire you
you know academic infrastructure it's an
it's not gonna happen
like I'm sorry that I'm being realistic
here it's not gonna happen so what you
can do though is there something
individual can always do they can play
in the places that are the white space
the white space right now is for you to
put out curriculum on your own to the
world in a format like this or whatever
if you wanna make SlideShare is great
you want to do Khan Academy stuff great
you want to do SlideShare great you need
to work around the system not within it
Paul asks so spring is taking over the
Radio Shack stores but what is the
relevance of Sprint it's from the new
Radio Shack Platz a great question I
don't know what Sprint's got in mind for
Radio Shack
I think physical retail stores need to
be innovative and and have experiences
wrapped around them you're right I think
there's a very interesting point here
that if Sprint just puts up Sprint
stores and execute in a RadioShack way
they become the new RadioShack if they
don't and they take a page out of let's
say Barnes and Nobles that realize they
couldn't keep Pete with Amazon if it was
just books and made it more of a coffee
shop place you visited a community hub
and they trickle down some sales from
that it all depends on the execution you
are what you are right people always
like hey our brand represents this so
this is what we have to do it's not true
what you do then becomes your brand and
so the execution of Sprint over the next
24 months will dictate if there's a new
RadioShack or the new sprint retail
store 3.0 Charles asks how do you hustle
faster Charles stop focusing on dumb
[ __ ] and just keep moving and don't be
scared of breaking anything and don't
think about perfection and there is no
perfect way to cross your T's and dot
your i's and don't be crippled and don't
be romantic and just move and have no
seconds to breathe and just schedule on
schedule on schedule 5 minute meetings
10 minute meetings 3 minute meetings 8
minute meetings and just move really
asks last year you nailed it when you
recommended us to you
medium what are your recommendations for
2015 I got nothing yet actually I do
have something
sorry India scare to crap idea and I'm
feeling tea Brock's gonna use this
footage LinkedIn is catching my
attention I'm very shocked over what I'm
seeing over the last ten days of just
natively posting content in my LinkedIn
feed now I have a huge audience there
and so I don't know how that works out
for other people but linkedin's freaking
me out a little bit not I'm not talking
about pulse or like influencer I'm just
talking about my feed my account Yuri
how would you market a business in an
industry that has a bad reputation and
people only use it in emergencies let's
say for example hmm Tony industry thanks
Garry Matt this is a great question and
I've talked about this before if you're
in a towing industry what I would
actually be in is I would become a media
company in the travel and car industry I
would create a site that you know
especially if your regional I'm gonna
assume that you're doing this towing in
a regional area let's call it Kansas
City I'm just gonna call that I would
literally call like Kansas City Highway
com where you're reviewing the
restaurants you're giving people
shortcuts you become a community you
know hub of content and information and
then sprinkled throughout every third or
four posts you talk about your service
maybe you do a real hardcore right hook
where if they click or use the QR code
they put you your name and your
company's name into their phone and then
you can control that and put emergency
roadside assistance I like that that was
a really good idea that's what you
should do you should become the content
player around the culture of driving
highway culture travel and the general
area Damon asks Girl Scout cookies are
going on sale tomorrow if you were a
Girl Scout
how would you maximize yourself Damon
one of the moves I would use is try to
go viral and go very practical clouds
and dirt so I would do hardcore
one-on-one activation literally I would
have a five minute meeting with my
parents and asked them who their 11 best
friends are and then call them and ask
them to buy the damn cookies
I would also then go outside and knock
on every single door of every person and
I would ask them multiple times over
twice knock on doors and ring doorbells
in the course of a week
to show them that I'm gonna relentlessly
bother them until they buy a box of
cookies so hardcore aggressive in the
dirt stuff then I would try to do one
kind of viral move so I would take a
picture of me holding a sign saying if I
buy if you guys help me sell a thousand
boxes of cookies I'll do X right and so
that kind of stuff tends to work I would
do that on Instagram see if I could get
a couple of celebrities I'd hit up on
Twitter to show them awareness around
this and then try to create some sort of
big event that allows me to really blow
it out of the park going real up there
while that's trying to get viral
knocking on doors Daniel asks how do you
decide what to trust when it comes to
news media bias versus fact reporting
this is a tough question brother I mean
you know I don't think I have the answer
right like everybody's got their agenda
humans are flawed by Nature so
everyone's gonna put their spin on it I
you know what what I what I'm really
upset about is watching people only
gravitate to the people that are like
minded I take enormous pride in the fact
that I'll watch MSNBC CNBC Fox
I remember for a year there was
screaming hell Jazeera nothing not
because that I believe in any one
people's hyperbole it's just fun to
contextualize maybe I'm affected by the
fact that I grew up in a communist
country and my mom wrote a book report
that Fidel Castro was the bravest man in
the world right and because that was a
spend that she got of what he was doing
in Cuba against the US and and so you
know if you're self-aware enough to know
that people are driving their agenda and
that's just the way it is then what you
do is you start hedging everything right
and it creates some level of balance so
I think it's about being open-minded and
trying to challenge yourself to see it
from multiple perspectives but you know
at some level I think we trust the
people that most talk about the things
we talk about I think that some level
can be slightly dangerous especially now
in a social media digital content media
scale world there's so many more voices
that can be completely for us sort of
challenge you vaynernation to make sure
once a day once a week at least once a
month you're reading heavily with an
open mind the counterpoint the things
that you believe Home Instead Senior
Care asks hey Gary how can a small local
non Met
full in-home senior care agency
incorporate the Thank You economy into
our business with our clients and their
families there it's a piece of cake
actually I think you map the data of the
families of the clients and you follow
them on social follow them on Facebook
and Twitter see what they care about and
if somebody talks about being a huge
Padres fan maybe you ask their loved one
to take a picture with a Padres hat and
then you put it in a box the picture
physical yeah that still happens with
the Padres hat and you send it and say
how much fun you're having spending the
time with their loved one I'm sure
anybody who's got a loved one in a
certain situation getting a letter from
that place with this Padres hat because
you're a Padres fan and it's saying how
much you enjoy having their grandfather
or great-grandmother in the facility
would extremely warm their heart and
create a real depth moment and you're
doing it both physically because then
every time they wear that hat or see
that hat they think of that moment so
it's got more longevity and so the Thank
You economy is quite easy my friends the
Thank You economy is not about the
tactics that I just laid out but thank
you economy is about the religion of
actually doing it
Florian asks how do you see the world in
2018 once the Apple watch has probably
become a vital part in everybody's lives
all right it's a great question I think
the Apple watch has a significant chance
of winning I am 100% going to get it
today comes out to just try it
I think smart technology is coming not
only to our wrist but I think it's
coming to our collar I actually think in
2018 2020 2022 we'll start seeing the
smart shirt at scale where we could be
recording I mean I'm looking forward to
call Steve hey stunned when why is that
article not up you know like I'm looking
forward to that moment and so you know
how is it changed I you know anybody who
thinks that the smartphone which is
absolutely the most important product in
the world anybody who thinks that that's
where it ends is clearly not paying
attention to have the world works and so
the smartphone will be trumped maybe
they'll always be a device big we start
putting inside of ourselves but I do
think smart technology coming to other
things in our world our sneakers or hats
and definitely our collars I'm really
fascinated I invested in a company
called cord like it especially because
they're based around voice and I think
voice over typing I look everything
Eben's them flows right like like there
was hand
and then we went hardcore phone and now
we're back to handwritten but it's thumb
written and I think we'll go back to
voice I think it's gonna look like this
and es i base my Instagram on pics to my
GoPro any tips I'm differentiating my
content from other GoPro cats Andy this
will of to be a part two because I can't
give you tips without knowing what your
objectives and agenda are right and so I
need a little more color get back on the
show
Jared asks Gary why are you scared of
cows Jared I'm actually not scared of
cows as a matter of fact I grew up in
high school years in hundred and County
New Jersey and we had two cows big
shout-out Mashka and I'm really not
scared of cows I was just trying to make
the show entertaining Ryan asks some
companies timelines are nothing but
apologies such as Comcast should they
take a break from Twitter and fix their
product yes and even if your product is
completely broken you shouldn't be in
full apology mode at all times
John asks blackberry used to be socially
hip could a new social media approach
make a difference or is it too late it's
too late for blackberry I'm shocked the
stone business Erie asks hey Gary my
family has always believed so much in me
back in the days were you more afraid of
letting yourself down or your family you
know I've always been really worried
about letting myself down more so than
my parents kind of feel as though that
would be a trickle-down effect if I
worried about myself then my parents
would be proud so you know I took a lot
of pressure and my mom's belief in me
I took an enormous pressure my dad's
belief in me in the way that he kind of
like set me up for success and give me
all that autonomy at 22 years old to run
a company but it's always and forever
going to be about me for me you know
it's a very selfish thing you know to me
it's um I need to I need to make myself
proud and that's kind of how I navigate
as a human being and definitely as a
business man and look I'm not perfect
and nobody is and nothing the people
that know me the best they know the only
time I'm pissed and I'm feisty is what
I'm upset with myself
Kyle and you get very personal when
building your brand with the public how
personal is too personal where do you
draw the line Kyle I think for everybody
it's different right I draw a line
heavily around the kids right I don't do
a lot of stuff with Xander and Misha but
you know but I'm also thrilled to put
out a picture of me being on the toilet
right like so like everybody's got
different lines some people are very
conservative some people are extremely
aggressive like some people take photos
nude some don't even want to show their
belly button everybody's got their own
objectives their own agenda their own
northstar of what's too much for me I
just always go and gut feel what might
be too much last week might not be too
much tomorrow you know I don't really I
don't really second-guess my feelings
I've done pretty well with them and so
for me it's what I'm feeling of the
moment I like getting personal I think
it it allows people to get closer to you
I mean I love doing this show for that
reason and so that's where I'm at
automatic I am wondering what everyone
thinks of direct message on
is it an untapped resource autumn the
problem with direct message on an
Instagram right is that we're asking is
so far what I've seen is well actually
you know it's interesting Instagram
direct message is interesting because
most people are not following too many
people that they don't want to be
following on Instagram it's very
different than Twitter and other places
I mean really if you look at the farm
I'd love to look at the big data of
Instagram because I have a feeling that
most of the direct message stuff is a
hell of a lot more scandalous and a hell
of a lot more inappropriate than I think
people realize you know from anecdotally
what I'm hearing is happening with
Instagram direct messaging is a hell of
a lot of flirting and a hell of a lot of
I'm traveling for the right words here
so you know because you're only
following people you want to follow I
think I think from a marketing
standpoint it's hard to get into that
because I look at it like texting it's a
place where people have no interest and
having people market to them and I would
stay very away from Instagram direct
messaging as a marketing tactic because
I think it's an inappropriate place to
go AJ asks how can I engage with an
audience whose interests are private to
them
AJ great name first of all Facebook
Facebook dark posts there's a way to use
the interest graph to get to these
people who don't want to talk about
whatever misgivings or things that are
embarrassed of or not interested in you
can go and look at you know you can get
into the MasterCard data and see what
they're buying you know you could
there's obviously a lot of brands in
this space actually app hair loss is
that we're talking about can you pull up
can somebody pull up row gains Facebook
page right now just for kicks and
giggles the real-time action just gonna
wait I'm gonna wait AJ pretty small of
course nobody wants to talk about who
wants to be like oh cool I'm losing my
hair I can't wait to be a fan of Rogaine
but how big is it there's no page
there's like a different drug page the
Tetons
like there's no brand paid for Rogaine
you sure
nonetheless as he's going through that
the 870 people that were okay with going
on the unofficial page there probably is
a page good because I think Steve will
eventually find it or there's
alternative brands playing in the space
the truth is there's a couple ways to go
about it
I would target men and certain age
groups
there's also female hair loss the
Facebook has enough data for you to get
there whether you're going after doctors
fan pages that play in the space brands
again it's absolutely correct that most
people aren't going to talk about it on
Twitter or follow but some are and
that's enough and then what I would say
is you get to the four or five 15:17
p-paige --is that people are fans up you
you go against that and then you create
a look-alike audience against that you
also take the data you have I don't know
if you're selling direct but if you have
any email data or anything of that
nature you can create look-alike
audiences that's people's behaviors
similar on Facebook and that's where
you're getting your scale from you got
something step on yeah so whale here we
go so I mean look there's thirty six
thousand people that are a fan of the
Rogaine page and so you're able to
actually go after the people that did
that and so you know I would go after
that crew and look-alike audiences
against that and and you know I think
SEM you know this is an example where I
think search probably wins very heavily
you know because that's a more private
action and so I would buy a lot of
keywords on Google Bing no Lori asks if
Lizzie opened up a business as direct
competition to vaynermedia or Wine
Library what would you do
Laurie I would put Lizzie directly out
of [ __ ] business I mean that that
would be no hesitation when it comes to
war look I mean I wish AJ was here I
think he's an Oklahoma busy or Tennessee
on business
yeah I mean under the context of the
Jets in football and business I will
slash anyone's face with a hose I don't
know what that means but I like if I
came home and Lee sees like I'm starting
Lizzie media and we're gonna crush it
I'm like that's great I'm gonna put you
directly out of
that would be the answer Mike asks Gary
why do you put so much emphasis on to
sports such as the Jets I don't know
Mike truth is I really don't know I mean
you know when I psychoanalyze myself I
think the Jets specifically was when I
was five six years old was the first
kind of like Americana thing often like
saying I learned how to speak English
watching the Jets I mean that's some of
it was really scooby-doo and the great
space coaster and price is right but the
Jets were really kind of that first
American thing that I associated with
the kids in the neighborhood around and
you get into you know you get into
rhythm right it's like working out or
reading like if my cadence became like I
watch the Jets and then you go through
all those emotions over 35 years you
start really building a loyalty to it
the the Downs and the Downs and the
slight ups and the downs and so you know
I think I don't know why I put so much
emphasis around it I don't really have
the full pledge thing but that's my best
guess even asks I'm starting a wedding
invitation and stationary boutique
called spoken for co I publish a post on
the company blog every Tuesday I spend
10 to 15 hours on each post I create
visuals to promote these posts on social
media however I realize that I'm getting
way more likes on my hand-drawn
lettering post compared to these non
hand-drawn lines what should I do
Vivian you're spending way too much time
on it in my opinion 10 to 15 hours feels
completely disproportional to the value
exchange that you're getting in return
you need to figure out how to do it
faster you also need to become a little
less romantic and you need to figure out
what your micro version of that is
because content is a gateway drug to
opportunity and I think your supply and
demand or your value and return for the
time is off kilter you're also in a
space and you're part of this world
because you love the design and the
creation and you're an artist at heart
and so I don't want to tell you what to
do but from a business context and
that's why you asked it on this show I
think there's an inefficiency there and
you need to figure out how to make that
10 to 15 hours closer to 1 to 2 max 45
minutes preferably so you can do a hell
of a lot more every Tuesdays not enough
I need it more often the only way I can
get it more often from you is if you
allow yourself to go faster this was
back to an earlier question this
marathon of tees and eyes I think
way to down the perfection variable and
so to prove out my point I would ask you
to try to do what you can do do me a
favor next to they spend two hours on it
see what it does and see what the
results are you may learn from that and
if and if you hate what happens and
there's not a lot of engagement do it
one more time and if you can get me to
three strikes where it doesn't work in
three straight Tuesday's then you can go
back to do your thing
but my gut tells me that won't be the
case Lisa asked what's your spirit
animal and Lisa finally so everybody
thanks so much for hanging with me that
was fun the marathon is fun I have a
funny feeling we're getting a lot of
comments have like this is what you
should do you'll get so many more
answers I got so much more value Lisa my
spirit animal is battle cat from heme
actually Ram man Ram man from he-man if
you don't know what it looks like it
looks like this question of the day what
is your spirit animal you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
I got nothing yet actually I do have
something
sorry India scared the crap out of you
and I'm feeling tea Brock's gonna use
this footage